welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one of many spider-man no way
home's curiosities is peter parker's new
suit no no no not that one the other one
no not that one either we're getting
colder we're talking about the gold
integrated suit but to be fair peter
does have quite a few costume changes in
this movie but i think there's a reason
because the story behind peter's
acquisition of this integrated suit
actually tells us a lot about the film
peter's relationship with his villains
and with his alternate selves so let's
break down everything we know about this
no way home integrated suit one of the
most interesting details about this suit
is that peter seems to switch in or out
of it relatively quickly seemingly
within one moment of the same scene in
the second trailer peter is wearing the
gold integrated suit as he leaps to
catch the green goblin pumpkin grenade
as it explodes this location looks like
the lobby of the feast homeless outreach
center based on the feast truck parked
out front of the building as it's
attacked from the outside and we see
aunt may running through this lobby as
the police lights are flickering on the
walls coming from the outside but then
there's another shot of ant-may patting
peter's chest both of them looking a
little cooked as if they were in the
vicinity of a fire or an explosion
however you will notice that peter in
this shot is now not wearing the gold
integrated suit but rather his red
fabric suit from the end of far from
home that he's wearing in the opening
act of no way home so what's going on
here well this distinction might tell us
something about the functionality of the
gold integrated suit which if you look
at the shots we've seen in other promo
footage and in the close-up
visualizations that we've gotten from
official merch they show us that this
suit is really a combination of the
metal armor peter had in his iron spider
suit and the classic red fabric that he
had in his past suits and the gold
components may be connected to the
golden iron spider appendages that this
gold integrated suit still seems capable
of releasing these parts may be all that
is left of peter's iron spider armor
after doc ock absorbs the red nanotech
from peter's suit onto otto's arms you
know getting these nerd theories wrong
sucks but you know what sucks worse wet
socks especially this time of year to
keep your little piggies dry you don't
have to resort to wearing some big old
nasty boots you can wear some sleek
comfortable messy shoes thank you to
vessy for sponsoring this video you're
welcome eric don't talk to me shoes i
only talk to you i just wanna be a
friend besties are the perfect everyday
shoe besties are sustainably made knit
sneakers that are 100 waterproof they
keep your winter feet dry and warm
without any of the clunkiness of boots
oh
they're made with this dimetex material
that's super easy to clean with just a
rinse of water oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are blown
dry like the dune sea thanks bessie hey
whatever this season vessies are truly
an everyday shoe keep them by your door
wear them no matter whatever the weather
and thank me later there's no place like
dry feet there's no place like dry feet
there's no oh we're doing an ad check
out bessie in the link below and use the
code new rockstars to get 25 off what
your vesty shoes also get up to 30 off
on select messy vault items from
december 6 to january 1st what a deal
thanks bessie
now aesthetically this functions as a
kind of reversal of the tech heavy iron
manization of spider-man suits that some
viewers have griped about in the mcu
take on the character if you think about
it leaving only the gold parts does
mirror the evolution that tony stark's
first red and gold armor took when he
designed the mark iii in the first iron
man film his armor was originally going
to be a purely gold titanium alloy a
little ostentatious don't you think what
was i thinking you're usually so
discreet tell you what throw a little
hot rod red in there yes that should
help you keep a low profile boy boy do i
miss the sass betani brought into the
mcu before they gave him a body with a
purple you know but peter wears the gold
integrated suit for most of the battle
of the statue of liberty in no way home
making that quick change with the shot
of ant-may post-explosion an interesting
mystery it makes me wonder that in order
to save aunt may from that exploding
grenade peter's golden components from
his suit might detach and then
reassemble into protective armor around
aunt may a sort of restaging of that big
iron man 3 moment when tony stark used
his mark 42 components to wrap around
pepper potts and protect her from that
blast and when you think about it the
plating on the mark 42 armor was light
gold and long after that version of the
armor was retired and replaced with
later models in age of ultron and civil
war and homecoming that movie spider-man
homecoming randomly brought back the
iron man mark 42 armor as an easter egg
in that film one of the suits in the
stark jet as happy hogan transported the
last of tony's stuff out of avengers
tower the jet that the vulture was
trying to hijack and now we know this
film no way home is scavenging from old
stark tech with electro using tony
stark's old generation new element arc
reactor mark 1 or mark ii with the
triangular inlay that tony invented in
iron man 2 and then continued to use a
version of in iron man 3 until he threw
it off the coast of malibu and replaced
it with a wearable chest reactor in the
future mcu titles so who knows the gold
components of peter's integrated suit
could come from the same toy stark mark
42 armor and this again puts the mystery
of avengers tower back in the spotlight
for no way home tony stark sold it to
some unknown new occupant back in
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home teased that that new owner
must be remodeling it by having peter
glide through a newly constructed atrium
in that tower in the final scene ever
since the mystery remained dormant until
episode 2 of hawkeye when clinton barton
and kate bishop had this exchange let me
guess we're going to your safe house
is it an avengers tower no tommy sold
that a few years ago
that is so sad on so many of us now just
tell me who bought avengers tower oh
yeah that's right they sold avengers
tower
uh oh actually i do know who bought
avengers tower say nothing goodness
gracious
well thank you so much i can't wait to
see
if the big reveal in this hawkeye series
is truly going to be wilson fisk kingpin
visit dinafrio someone desperate to
acquire item scavenged from avengers
real estate that would pose kingpin as a
possible collector or supplier of this
former stark tech in spider-man no way
home and that new occupant of avengers
tower which seems like a very real
possibility especially if charlie cox
matthew murdock actually does show up in
this movie as well really i think
peter's progression into the gold
integrated suit will be as the suit
progressions always are in these movies
a function of what the plot needs from
him and his own character growth like a
hermit crab outgrowing the shell in this
case peter's return to the old school
fabric could be a move he makes at the
behest of and with the engineering
guidance of alternate peter parker's and
neither of whom had an iron man or an
iron man lab to help them stitch their
suits something they did themselves and
one of whom had to build his own web
shooters that's one of the bigger design
upgrades of the integrated suit over the
iron spider armor the iron spider had
these bulky web shooters covering
peter's wrists giving peter's arms a
kind of mega man silhouette the web
shooters on his new integrated suit are
more flush with his wrist hidden under
the fabric practically speaking this
gives peter's hands more flexibility and
maneuverability with how precisely he
can aim his web shooters which will come
in handy when he needs that hand to
catch a fallen girlfriend tom holland
himself may have referenced this whole
diy spirit of the peter parker legacy by
sharing on his instagram story a meme of
toby maguire peter parker's very first
diy suit at the wrestling ring so yeah
it really does seem like peter's
integrated suit seems to begin at least
as an upgrade free from the nanotech
that doc ock would snatch away from him
but then as a metaphor of peter's
progression into a hybrid of that diy
fabric that he returns to after his
world integrates with other parallel
realities in alternate peters but still
possibly incorporating components of the
gold-plated past from his start in this
cinematic universe integration hey to
support this channel check out one of
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstar some more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you